un soir de réveillon car porte le
costume pourvu qu'il soit brillant en
voyant affriolants on va les voir l'élu
est pourvu qu'il fasse tourner les têtes
ou juste une tenue pour faire la fête là
vous êtes relooké à un message y asseoir
comme quoi on devait être habillé d'une
tenue hawaïenne ou africaines ou
tropiques
pour nadia à 15 ans de métier une
clientèle d'habitués mais jamais la même
demande
le costume rayé costume de gants servent
pour fêter 2019
la tendance est aux années folles c'est
quand même quelque chose qui permet
d'être déguisé même temps qui peut être
classe surtout chez la femme
je pense que c'est un bon thème pour ça
la star de cette année la commerçante
l'a repéré devant sa série préférée sur
netflix je pense que tout le monde
connaît la cata des papes est là après
faut avoir le feeling et s'intéresser et
beaucoup et on l'a senti venir
et d'ailleurs je demande à mes
fournisseurs avant qu'il me le propose
ici un costume coûte entre 20 et 50
euros
mais une fois qu'on a trouvé son
déguisement il reste quelques 5 on tour
nable pour faire la fête car qui dit
réveillon dit toujours cotillons
inévitable au moment fatidique
c'est surtout pour marquer le coup en
fait de l'heure de minuit et puis que
aussi pour un peu resté dans les esprits
je pense ça va durer un quart d'heure
vingt minutes il y en a par ailleurs a
partout dans la maison et puis peut-être
qu'on fera le gâteau une valeur sûre
pour ce magasin en décembre ce gérant
fait un tiers de son chiffre rien
qu'avec les recettes des deux derniers
jours impossible de fermer le dimanche
cette année année on est à moins 40% par
rapport à l'année dernière fut la perte
entre
la zone et gilet jaune toutes les
interdictions de vente d'artifices qui
ont eu lieu géré sur les week-ends donc
on essaie de récupérer un peu notre
chiffre d'affaires les retardataires
n'ont plus que quelques heures pour
mettre les petits plats dans les grands
fin prêt pour le nouvel-an